Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Coffee had just arrived when the French squadron signaled. The Tsar made me go up on the bridge with him. It was a magnificent spectacle. In a quivering silvery light, the France slowly surged forward over the turquoise and emerald waves, leaving a long white furrow behind her.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。法国舰队发出信号时，咖啡刚送上来。沙皇让我陪他登上舰桥。那是一场壮观的景象。在颤动的银色光影中，法兰西号在绿松石色和翡翠色的波浪上缓缓前行，身后留下一道长长的白色航迹。
Then she stopped majestically. The mighty warship which has brought the head of the French state is well worthy of her name. She was indeed France, coming to Russia. I felt my heart beating. For a few minutes there was a prodigious din in the harbour. The guns of the ships and the shore batteries firing, the crews cheering, the Marseillais answering the Russian national anthem, the cheers of thousands of spectators who had come from St. Petersburg on pleasure boats. At length, the President of the Republic stepped the French Republic,
随后，她庄严地停了下来。这艘载着法国国家元首的强大战舰，确实配得上她的名字。她确实就是法兰西，来到了俄罗斯。我感到心跳加速。港口里有几分钟响起了巨大的轰鸣声。舰船和岸上炮台鸣炮，船员们欢呼，马赛曲与俄罗斯国歌交织在一起，还有从圣彼得堡乘游船赶来的成千上万名观众的欢呼声。终于，共和国总统踏上了法兰西共和国的土地，
President Poincaré, on the 20th of July, 1914. And Dominic, up front, we'll be coming to Monsieur Paléologue a bit later. But just to say, this is a golden age for comical French ambassadors, isn't it? It is, absolutely. So there's the ambassador to St. Petersburg. The one to London is even better, and we'll be coming to him in due course. Paul Combon. Yeah, it's absolutely brilliant. But this is, I mean, aside from the colour of the ambassador himself, I mean, this is a crucial moment in the story of the road to the outbreak of the First World War, isn't it? Because you have the Tsar and the President of the French Republic,
1914年7月20日的普恩加莱总统。多米尼克，我们稍后再谈帕莱奥洛格先生。但我想说，这对于滑稽的法国大使来说是一个黄金时代，不是吗？确实如此。所以那是驻圣彼得堡的大使。驻伦敦的那位更好，我们稍后会谈到他。保罗·康邦。是的，这绝对太精彩了。但撇开大使本人的色彩不谈，这是通往第一次世界大战爆发之路的关键时刻，不是吗？因为你有沙皇和法兰西共和国总统，
two heads of state allied either side of Germany, the Western and the Eastern flank respectively, meeting up in St. Petersburg. Yes. And also, Tom, we ended last time with the Austrians preparing their ultimatum. The Austrians have been writing their ultimatum, but they have not yet delivered it. So they're waiting for the French to leave St. Petersburg before they will deliver it to Serbia. So they are meeting in ignorance of what they suspect something may be coming, but they don't really know what it is. And so that makes this meeting all the more kind of pregnant with possibility. So last time, in the last couple of episodes, we talked about Austria and Germany. Let's turn our attention now to their great antagonist,
两位盟国元首分别位于德国的东西两侧，在圣彼得堡会面。是的。而且，汤姆，我们上次结束时提到奥地利人正在准备他们的最后通牒。奥地利人一直在起草最后通牒，但尚未发出。所以他们正在等待法国人离开圣彼得堡，然后才会将其交给塞尔维亚。因此，他们是在对即将发生的事情有所怀疑但并不真正了解的情况下会面的。这使得这次会面充满了各种可能性。所以上次，在过去几集里，我们谈到了奥地利和德国。现在让我们把注意力转向他们伟大的对手，
and we'll start with Russia. So Russia, Tsarist Russia, is the world's largest country, 164 million people, huge, multi-ethnic, multi-cultural empire. People compare it to the United States, don't they? Yeah. That it's a continental empire. Exactly. And just as America is rising, people talk of the rise of Russia. That is exactly the right comparison.
我们先从俄罗斯开始。俄罗斯，沙皇俄国，是世界上最大的国家，拥有1.64亿人口，是一个庞大、多民族、多元文化的帝国。人们常把它和美国相比，不是吗？是的。它是一个大陆帝国。没错。正如美国正在崛起一样，人们也在谈论俄罗斯的崛起。这正是恰当的比较。
Those days, of course, Eastern Poland, Finland, Ukraine, they were all part of the Russian Empire. At the head since 1894, the autocrat of all the Russias, Nicholas II. Of course, we all know what's going to happen to him in the Russian Revolution. He's a very conservative man, family man, nervous, stubborn, not terribly bright. Looks like George V. Yeah, it looks Looks like George V. Yeah, looks just like George V,
当然，在那个年代，东波兰、芬兰、乌克兰都是俄罗斯帝国的一部分。自1894年以来，全俄国的独裁者尼古拉二世一直处于领导地位。当然，我们都知道他在俄国革命中会发生什么。他是一个非常保守的人，顾家，神经质，固执，不太聪明。长得像乔治五世。是的，长得像乔治五世。是的，看起来就像乔治五世，
but sort of slightly more Charles I in personality, I would say. Oh, yes, and indeed fate. And in fate. And Russia has had a very tough beginning to the 20th century. They fought the Russo-Japanese War, in which they were utterly defeated. Then there was a little revolution. The Tsar had to call the Duma, a kind of parliament, which he didn't like doing. And ever since then, Russia has turned away. So all through the 19th century, Russia expanding in Asia.
但我认为他的性格更像查理一世。哦，是的，确实如此，命运也是。在命运上也是。俄罗斯在20世纪初经历了一个非常艰难的开端。他们打了日俄战争，结果惨败。然后发生了一场小革命。沙皇不得不召集杜马，一种他并不喜欢的议会。从那时起，俄罗斯就转向了。所以整个19世纪，俄罗斯都在亚洲扩张。
And it's great rivalry with the British in Asia, the great game. But since the Russo-Japanese War, they've slightly turned back westward. And their focus has been on their alliance with France, which they signed in 1894, and the Balkans. And their eyes have been fixed on Southeast Europe. And really, the question is, why? Because the Balkans are quite a long way from Russia. Now, some people say, and you'll see this repeated often, it's because of their mystical pan-Slav solidarity. And orthodoxy. And orthodoxy. And orthodoxy and all that sort of stuff. And there's a bit of truth in that,
以及它与英国在亚洲的伟大竞争，即“大博弈”。但自日俄战争以来，他们稍微转向了西方。他们的重点一直放在1894年签署的法俄同盟以及巴尔干半岛上。他们的目光一直锁定在东南欧。真正的问题是，为什么？因为巴尔干半岛离俄罗斯很远。现在，有些人说，你会经常看到这种说法，这是因为他们神秘的泛斯拉夫团结。还有东正教。还有东正教。还有东正教之类的东西。这其中有一点道理，
but I think only a bit. So it's the kind of thing that newspapers get very excited about. In the same way, I think, as British newspapers right now are talking about our kith and kin beyond the seas. There's something slightly self-parodic, I think, about it. Except that in Australia and Canada, they really are kith and kin, whereas the relationship between the Serbs and the Russians is much more loose. Yeah, exactly. It is. You're absolutely right. Another thing that people often talk about is Russia is the third Rome. The second Rome is still standing, Constantinople, and it's part of a kind of decaying Ottoman empire. And there are quite a lot of Russian nationalists who think, I'd love to have Constantinople. Imagine that commanding
但我认为只有一点。所以这是报纸非常兴奋的那种事情。我认为，就像英国报纸现在谈论我们海外的亲友一样。我认为这其中有一些自我讽刺的意味。除了在澳大利亚和加拿大，他们确实是亲友，而塞尔维亚人和俄罗斯人之间的关系要松散得多。是的，没错。确实如此。你说得完全正确。人们经常谈论的另一件事是俄罗斯是“第三罗马”。第二个罗马仍然屹立不倒，那就是君士坦丁堡，它是衰落的奥斯曼帝国的一部分。有很多俄罗斯民族主义者认为，我真想拥有君士坦丁堡。想象一下那个指挥
position, but at the city of the Caesars, that would be a brilliant thing. But also it's the strategic position of Constantinople, that it's the kind of the chokehold of the Bosphorus that links the Black Sea to the Mediterranean and therefore to the world. I mean, that's the crucial thing, isn't it? I think that's the important thing, actually, Tom. It's not whether or not they actually control Constantinople itself. It's whether they control the straits that lead from the Black Sea into the Mediterranean. Because in a nice sort of nod to events in the 2020s, Russia's economy depends upon Ukrainian grain exports. And the control of those straits is crucial to get those grain ships out of the Black Sea and into the Mediterranean. And if the straits are closed off, then Russia's economy is
位置，在凯撒之城，那将是一件了不起的事情。但这也是君士坦丁堡的战略地位，它是连接黑海和地中海，进而连接世界的博斯普鲁斯海峡的咽喉。我的意思是，这是关键所在，不是吗？我认为这才是重点，汤姆。这不在于他们是否真正控制了君士坦丁堡本身。而在于他们是否控制了从黑海通往地中海的海峡。因为在向2020年代事件致敬的同时，俄罗斯的经济依赖于乌克兰的粮食出口。控制这些海峡对于将那些运粮船从黑海运往地中海至关重要。如果海峡被封锁，那么俄罗斯的经济就会
in terrible trouble. And the Balkans are the hinterland to the straits. So it's very important, as the Russians see it, that no enemy power controls that hinterland and therefore, by extension, the straits themselves, because they could hold the Russians to ransom over the grain exports. They could stop the Russian Black Sea Fleet getting into the Mediterranean. And so it's a problem for the Russians, isn't it? The Balkans are kind of in a mess. So Ottoman power has collapsed. We've been talking about this in our previous episodes about the assassination of the Archduke. And you have all these kind of nationalist seething resentments bubbling away. And I suppose you could either say, well, that's a real problem, or you could say, you know, it's a good place to fish.
陷入可怕的困境。而巴尔干半岛是海峡的腹地。所以，在俄罗斯人看来，没有敌对势力控制那个腹地，从而间接控制海峡本身是非常重要的，因为他们可能会以粮食出口为要挟勒索俄罗斯人。他们可能会阻止俄罗斯黑海舰队进入地中海。所以这对俄罗斯人来说是个问题，不是吗？巴尔干半岛简直是一团糟。奥斯曼帝国的权力已经崩溃。我们在之前关于大公遇刺的剧集中讨论过这个问题。所有这些民族主义的怨恨都在沸腾。我想你可以说，这真是一个大问题，或者你可以说，这是一个很好的垂钓之地。
Yes, exactly. I think it's both. So I think their fear for them is if the Austrians get hegemony in the Balkans or some other power. But the opportunity is, I mean, they had backed Bulgaria. Now they've switched horses and they're backing Serbia. Serbia, as we said, has doubled in size since the Balkan Wars. So the Russians, you know, Serbia is their client. It hasn't all been plain sailing though, because the Russians have twice, as they see it, had to give ground in the Balkans. Once when Austria annexed Bosnia and the Serbs are very cross about it, but the Serbs and the Russians backed down. And again, during the Balkan Wars, there had been a great hullabaloo about whether or not
是的，完全正确。我认为两者兼而有之。所以我认为他们担心的是，如果奥地利人或其他势力在巴尔干半岛获得霸权。但机会在于，他们曾经支持保加利亚。现在他们换了马，转而支持塞尔维亚。正如我们所说，自巴尔干战争以来，塞尔维亚的规模扩大了一倍。所以俄罗斯人，你知道，塞尔维亚是他们的客户。但这并非一帆风顺，因为俄罗斯人认为他们已经在巴尔干半岛两次被迫让步。一次是奥地利吞并波斯尼亚，塞尔维亚人对此非常愤怒，但塞尔维亚人和俄罗斯人退缩了。在巴尔干战争期间，关于是否
Serbia was going to get Albania and access to the Adriatic. The Russians and Austrians had been slightly at daggers drawn about it. And again, Serbia and Russia had backed down. So the two sides there had drawn different lessons. The Austrians said, hey, listen, Serbs and the Russians will always back down. And the Russians said, we've done it twice. Yeah, never again. And we can't afford to do it again. Yeah. So that is a big problem. And the other thing, of course, is that Russia is in a different
塞尔维亚将获得阿尔巴尼亚和进入亚得里亚海的通道，曾引起轩然大波。俄罗斯人和奥地利人对此有些剑拔弩张。同样，塞尔维亚和俄罗斯再次退缩了。所以双方从中吸取了不同的教训。奥地利人说，嘿，听着，塞尔维亚人和俄罗斯人总是会退缩的。而俄罗斯人说，我们已经退缩两次了。是的，绝不再退。我们负担不起再次退缩的代价。是的。所以这是一个大问题。当然，另一件事是俄罗斯处于不同的
place in 1914 than it was before then. Because as we said in the last episode, Russia has been modernizing very fast. It has been spending huge amounts of money training its men on armaments and above all on its railways so their army is now the biggest in the world it's going to be two million people by the end of the 1910s bigger than germany and austria put together they are feeling much more self-confident than they were even 10 years earlier but there is another thing actually the guy called dominic levin has a book called Towards the Flame about Russia and the origins of the First World War, which is a brilliant book if people are interested in Russia. The Russians, like the Austrians and like the Germans, have this sort of ticking clock at the back of their heads.
位置，1914年与之前不同。因为正如我们在上一集所说，俄罗斯一直在快速现代化。它一直在投入巨资训练士兵、购买军备，最重要的是建设铁路，所以他们的军队现在是世界上规模最大的，到1910年代末将达到200万人，比德国和奥地利加起来还要多。他们比10年前更加自信。但实际上还有另一件事，一个叫多米尼克·列文的人写了一本关于俄罗斯和第一次世界大战起源的书，叫《走向火焰》，如果人们对俄罗斯感兴趣，这是一本很棒的书。俄罗斯人，像奥地利人和德国人一样，脑后有一种滴答作响的时钟。
So in their case, the ticking clock is they are frightened, not that the Ottoman Empire will fall apart, but the Ottoman Empire will actually stage a bit of a comeback. The Ottomans have just ordered two dreadnoughts from a British firm, Armstrong and Vickers, and they've got five more to come further down the line. And do the Russians have any dreadnoughts in the Black Sea? They do not. Right. So when all those Ottoman ships arrive, the Russians will be outnumbered in the black sea six to one and their foreign minister a guy called sergey sazanov says to his colleagues this will be absolutely calamitous for our ambitions we cannot he says stand by and watch the expansion of the ottoman navy because that will torpedo forever our chance of getting a hold, getting control of the straits on which our economy depends. And the Ottomans could close the straits.
所以对他们来说，滴答作响的时钟是他们害怕的不是奥斯曼帝国会分崩离析，而是奥斯曼帝国实际上会卷土重来。奥斯曼人刚刚向一家英国公司阿姆斯特朗和维克斯订购了两艘无畏舰，未来还有五艘。俄罗斯人在黑海有无畏舰吗？他们没有。对。所以当所有那些奥斯曼舰船抵达时，俄罗斯人在黑海的兵力将以六比一处于劣势，他们的外交大臣谢尔盖·萨佐诺夫对同事们说，这对我们的野心来说将是绝对灾难性的。他说，我们不能袖手旁观，看着奥斯曼海军扩张，因为那将永远摧毁我们获得控制权、控制我们经济所依赖的海峡的机会。而且奥斯曼人可能会封锁海峡。
They could close the straits, exactly. That sense of urgency is really important for the Russians. So I mentioned Sergei Sazonov. He is a massive figure in this story. He's not a household name by any means, but he's a really, really important figure because he is the person who basically directs russian policy in the whole of this story and he is the foreign minister he's been foreign ministers since 1910 the caricature is always that they are kind of reactionary warmongers itching for conflict in sasanoff's case's actually, everyone says he's actually quite a decent chap. He's very anti-German, isn't he?
他们可能会封锁海峡，没错。这种紧迫感对俄罗斯人来说非常重要。所以我提到了谢尔盖·萨佐诺夫。他是这个故事中的一个重量级人物。他绝不是家喻户晓的名字，但他是一个非常、非常重要的人物，因为他基本上指导了整个故事中的俄罗斯政策，他是外交大臣，自1910年以来一直担任外交大臣。人们总是讽刺他们是渴望冲突的反动战争贩子，就萨佐诺夫而言，每个人都说他实际上是一个相当正派的人。他非常反德，不是吗？
He doesn't like the Germans. And he's very pro-Serb. Exactly, he is. He looks like a bank manager. He's got his short man, he's got his bald head, kind of beard. Dominic Levin says of him,
他不喜欢德国人。而且他非常亲塞尔维亚。没错，他是。他看起来像个银行经理。他个子不高，秃头，留着胡子。多米尼克·列文这样评价他，
one of the kindest and most decent men ever to serve as Russian foreign minister. Well, let's be honest, that's not saying much. I guess that's true. I guess that's true. I guess that's true. He's no Sergei Lavrov.
有史以来担任俄罗斯外交大臣的最善良、最正派的人之一。好吧，老实说，这说明不了什么。我想这是真的。我想这是真的。我想这是真的。他可不是谢尔盖·拉夫罗夫。
No. He had the broad culture and polite manners of a well-educated European gentleman of the day. I mean, actually, I think by and large, ambassadors do like Sazonov. They think he's a cultivated, civilized man. He's very highly strung. He's very nervous and so on.
不。他拥有当时受过良好教育的欧洲绅士的广博文化和礼貌举止。我的意思是，实际上，我认为总的来说，大使们确实喜欢萨佐诺夫。他们认为他是一个有教养、文明的人。他非常紧张，非常神经质等等。
And his view of Balkan politics is, like everybody else really in this story, he thinks you rise or you fall, life is struggle. Some countries are doomed to fragmentation and disappearance from the map, and others are doomed to rise. Younger, more vital nations. And he thinks Austria is finished and Serbia is on a historical mission. He talks about its historical path and one day it will reach its promised land in the territory of Austria-Hungary. That's how a lot of Russian writers think about Balkan politics. He almost thinks that basically the laws of history have doomed Austria-Hungary and indeed the Ottoman Empire, and it's kind of illegitimate for them to resist that.
他对巴尔干政治的看法，和这个故事里的其他人一样，他认为你要么崛起，要么衰落，生活就是斗争。有些国家注定要分裂并从地图上消失，而另一些国家则注定要崛起。更年轻、更有活力的国家。他认为奥地利完了，塞尔维亚肩负着历史使命。他谈到它的历史道路，有一天它将到达它在奥匈帝国领土上的应许之地。这就是许多俄罗斯作家对巴尔干政治的看法。他几乎认为历史规律注定了奥匈帝国乃至奥斯曼帝国的灭亡，他们反抗这种规律是不合法的。
They should just step aside and let history take its course. It's like a bison. Yeah. On the Great Plains in the 1870s. Exactly. It's doomed. It's like one of our old friends, General Sherman or Sheridan, talking about the bison. Exactly that.
他们应该退后，让历史顺其自然。就像野牛一样。是的。1870年代大平原上的野牛。没错。它注定要灭亡。就像我们的老朋友谢尔曼将军或谢里丹将军谈论野牛一样。正是如此。
And the comparison, again, between the Russians and the Americans has often been made about late 19th century, sort of these great expansionist empires. So when the Archduke is assassinated, Sassanoff, Christopher Clarke in his book The Sleep Book, there's a brilliant section on Sassanoff and his documents to all his ambassadors. He, within days, constructs, and I don't think it's entirely contrived, I think he believes it, an alternative narrative about what happened that day. He says, listen, everybody hated Franz Ferdinand. So when the Austrians say they're really upset about it, that's nonsense. They didn't give a damn about Franz Ferdinand. If there was a plot against Franz Ferdinand, it's only because everybody in Bosnia hates the Austrians. And that just shows what terrible people they are. The killers were Bosnian. I mean, to say it's because of Serbia is absurd and just a contrivance. It's just a pretext because the Austrians already wanted to strike Serbia. Austria has actually no right to just accuse Serbia willy-nilly and to take action against her.
而且，俄罗斯人和美国人之间的比较经常被用来形容19世纪末这些伟大的扩张主义帝国。所以当大公遇刺时，萨佐诺夫，克里斯托弗·克拉克在他的书《梦游者》中，有一段关于萨佐诺夫和他给所有大使的文件，非常精彩。他在几天之内构建了一个关于那天发生的事情的替代叙事，我不认为这是完全捏造的，我认为他相信这一点。他说，听着，每个人都讨厌弗朗茨·斐迪南。所以当奥地利人说他们对此感到非常难过时，那是胡说八道。他们根本不在乎弗朗茨·斐迪南。如果有人密谋反对弗朗茨·斐迪南，那只是因为波斯尼亚的每个人都讨厌奥地利人。这恰恰说明他们是多么糟糕的人。凶手是波斯尼亚人。我的意思是，说这是因为塞尔维亚是荒谬的，只是一个借口。这只是一个借口，因为奥地利人本来就想打击塞尔维亚。奥地利实际上没有权利随意指责塞尔维亚并对她采取行动。
And ultimately, if the Austrians are making a great fuss about this, we all know why it is. They're just the Mozart-loving puppets of the strutting generals in Berlin, who are the people who are really pulling the strings. And so he sees Germany as the real enemy, doesn't he? He does. And as Chris Clark says, that interpretation of the events of the summer of 1914,
最终，如果奥地利人对此大惊小怪，我们都知道原因。他们只是柏林那些傲慢将军们的莫扎特爱好者傀儡，那些将军才是真正幕后操纵的人。所以他把德国视为真正的敌人，不是吗？他确实如此。正如克里斯·克拉克所说，那种对1914年夏天事件的解读，
it's not just very enduring, it's the interpretation that large numbers of people have right now. That there are people listening to this podcast who say, yes, Sazonov was right. That is what people think. Who cares about the Archduke? The Austrians, they didn't have any right to attack Serbia, and the Germans were pulling in the strings anyway.
不仅非常持久，而且是现在很多人持有的解读。听这个播客的人会说，是的，萨佐诺夫是对的。人们就是这么想的。谁在乎大公呢？奥地利人，他们根本没有权利攻击塞尔维亚，而且德国人反正是在幕后操纵。
So that's a narrative that you get right then and there, and it's constructed even before the ultimatum was issued. I think it's really important to make that point. So the Russians, they start to hear whispers in the middle of July, before the ultimatum, they start to hear rumors that there was going to be an ultimatum. They've actually intercepted telegrams from the Italian embassy in St. Petersburg that seem to show that the Austrians have started to put out feelers to the Italians, because the Italians are normally the Austrians' allies,
所以这是一个当时就有的叙事，而且在最后通牒发出之前就已经构建好了。我认为提出这一点非常重要。所以俄罗斯人，他们在7月中旬，在最后通牒之前，开始听到耳语，开始听到有最后通牒的传言。他们实际上截获了意大利驻圣彼得堡大使馆的电报，这些电报似乎显示奥地利人已经开始向意大利人试探，因为意大利人通常是奥地利人的盟友，
to see whether the Italians are all right with this. So they kind of know this is happening. And Sazonov raises it with the Russian ambassador and says then and there, if they do this, there will be a world inferno. He says Russia cannot tolerate it if the Austrians get stuck in against Serbia. And of course, what makes this so ominous is that the Russians themselves have powerful allies. And this brings us on, Tom Jaya, our old enemies, the French. And allies, Dominic.
看看意大利人是否同意这一点。所以他们多少知道这件事正在发生。萨佐诺夫向俄罗斯大使提出了这个问题，并当即表示，如果他们这样做，将会有一场世界大火。他说，如果奥地利人对塞尔维亚动手，俄罗斯无法容忍。当然，让这一切如此不祥的是，俄罗斯人自己也有强大的盟友。这就引出了我们，汤姆·贾亚，我们的老敌人，法国人。还有盟友，多米尼克。
And allies, our beloved allies. Yeah, England's great friends, the French. So the French obviously have a lot of skin in the game, as it were, because the big thing for the French, France is a smaller country than Germany now. I mean, wasn't it? And now its population has declined and its territory has declined because it's lost its Alsace and Lorraine to Germany. We talked about that. I mean, it's an amazing thing, actually. For as long as France had ever existed, France had been the great powerhouse of Europe, hadn't it?
还有盟友，我们敬爱的盟友。是的，英国的好朋友，法国人。所以法国人显然在其中投入了很多，因为对法国人来说，法国现在是一个比德国小的国家。我的意思是，不是吗？现在它的人口减少了，领土也减少了，因为它失去了阿尔萨斯和洛林给德国。我们谈过这个。我的意思是，这实际上是一件令人惊奇的事情。只要法国存在，法国一直是欧洲的强大力量，不是吗？
Culturally, militarily, demographically. And suddenly after 1870, the French are in the shade. But I suppose culturally they still are. I mean, Paris is the capital of Europe. It is. French remains the language of diplomacy and so on. It is. But when people publish, there's these league tables of industrial production and all that kind of thing. It's Germany, not France, that is challenging Britain. And similarly, look at British politicians, British writers at the turn of the 20th century. Germany is kind of the up and coming cool place to copy.
在文化上、军事上、人口上。突然在1870年之后，法国人处于阴影之中。但我认为在文化上他们仍然是。我的意思是，巴黎是欧洲的首都。确实如此。法语仍然是外交语言等等。确实如此。但当人们发布工业生产之类的排行榜时，是德国，而不是法国，在挑战英国。同样，看看20世纪初的英国政治家、英国作家。德国是那种正在崛起、值得效仿的酷地方。
Yeah. But if you want to become a famous painter, you're not going to Berlin. But I don't, Tom. You're going to Montmartre. Yeah, but I'm just saying. My art teacher told my parents I was the single worst person she'd ever taught at art. This obviously explains why you're such a keen fan of German militarism. Yeah. All stands revealed. Clearly. Clearly. Anyway, listen, the big trauma for France is obviously that Franco-Prussian war.
是的。但如果你想成为一名著名的画家，你不会去柏林。但我不是，汤姆。你要去蒙马特。是的，但我只是说。我的美术老师告诉我父母，我是她教过的最差劲的学生。这显然解释了为什么你如此热衷于德国军国主义。是的。一切都真相大白了。显然。显然。总之，听着，法国的巨大创伤显然是普法战争。
Their Emperor Napoleon III, a ridiculous and terrible man, captured by the Germans. Although he did meet my great-great-grandfather at his hotel on the Isle of Wight. Did he? Did your great-great-grandfather say to him, how could you betray the Emperor Maxim in mexico in that terrible way i don't know but i i do think you know i have a soft spot for him as a result okay well i don't the german empire had been proclaimed in versailles alsace lorraine had been taken by the germans and there are tons of people in france in 1914 who are still very very haunted by this i think I think. So France, in reaction to this, had gone into alliance with the Russians. And actually, the Franco-Russian alliance is more than just a kind of diplomatic alliance.
他们的皇帝拿破仑三世，一个荒谬而糟糕的人，被德国人俘虏了。虽然他在怀特岛的酒店里见过我的曾曾祖父。是吗？你的曾曾祖父有没有对他说，你怎么能以那种可怕的方式背叛墨西哥的马克西米连皇帝？我不知道，但我确实认为，你知道，我因此对他有一点好感。好吧，我没有。德意志帝国已经在凡尔赛宫宣布成立，阿尔萨斯-洛林被德国人夺走，1914年的法国有很多人仍然对此感到非常、非常困扰，我想。所以法国为了应对这一点，与俄罗斯结成了同盟。实际上，法俄同盟不仅仅是一种外交同盟。
It's a cultural thing. I was really struck by... Have you ever had a Russian salad? I have. Yes, it's horrible. It's terrible, yeah. Yeah, it's kind of lumps of stuff in a kind of mayonnaise, watery mayonnaise soup. It's a terrible, terrible salad.
这是一种文化现象。我真的很受触动……你吃过俄式沙拉吗？我吃过。是的，很难吃。太糟糕了，是的。是的，那是一种在某种蛋黄酱、水状蛋黄酱汤里的块状物。那是一种非常、非常糟糕的沙拉。
So the first recipe for that was printed in 1894, which was the year of the alliance. It was dreamed up by a French chef. So if you eat that, you're literally eating Franco-Russian imperialism. And the fact is there were postcards, there were cartoons, there were recipes, there was all this to celebrate this alliance because it's basically two quite anxious powers who are frightened about Germany, and that alliance means a huge amount to them. But Dominic, also, just to ask, I mean, it is the most autocratic of autocratic monarchies, and it is really Europe's only significant republic. Yeah. A republic kind of founded on the execution of a king.
所以第一份食谱是在1894年印刷的，那正是同盟的那一年。它是由一位法国厨师构思出来的。所以如果你吃了那个，你实际上就是在吃法俄帝国主义。事实上，有明信片、漫画、食谱，所有这些都是为了庆祝这个同盟，因为这基本上是两个对德国感到恐惧的焦虑大国，那个同盟对他们意义重大。但多米尼克，还要问一下，我的意思是，这是独裁君主制中最独裁的，而且它确实是欧洲唯一重要的共和国。是的。一个建立在处决国王基础上的共和国。
Yeah, crazy. So a sign, actually, that this is not really ideological. I mean, I always think this is a real problem for people who say the First World War was a noble crusade. Like, really? With Russia on your side? I mean, how do you explain? Anyway, President Poincaré, who you mentioned arriving in St. Petersburg, he is from Lorraine.
是的，太疯狂了。所以，实际上，这表明这并不是真正的意识形态。我的意思是，我一直认为这对那些说第一次世界大战是一场高尚十字军的人来说是一个真正的问题。真的吗？有俄罗斯站在你这边？我的意思是，你怎么解释？总之，你提到的抵达圣彼得堡的普恩加莱总统，他来自洛林。
He is from a part of France that was dismembered and part of it taken by the German empire. His hometown was occupied by the Germans when he was 10 years old. His family fled west. They did get it back eventually. But at 10 years old, you feel this, right? You're not four, you're 10 and you notice it. And he said, in my years at school, I saw no other reason to live than the possibility of recovering our lost provinces. And when he becomes a dominant French politics, sort of Edwardian era, I think there is a sense in France that, you know, we have basically been the whipping boy for too long.
他来自法国的一部分，那部分被德意志帝国肢解并占领了。他10岁时，他的家乡被德国人占领。他的家人向西逃亡。他们最终确实收复了它。但在10岁时，你会有这种感觉，对吧？你不是4岁，你是10岁，你会注意到这一点。他说，我在学校的那些年里，除了收复我们失去的省份的可能性之外，我没有看到其他活下去的理由。当他成为爱德华时代法国政治的主导人物时，我认为法国有一种感觉，你知道，我们基本上被当作替罪羊太久了。
We've been licking our wounds. You know, we've been tearing ourselves apart about the Dreyfus case, big espionage case, all this kind of thing. And actually enough of that now. Let's get back on our feet again. There was a book, Young People Today, published in 1913. War. That word has suddenly acquired a certain prestige, a young new word radiating the kind of attraction that an age old warmongering instinct has revived in the hearts of men. Young people see in it all the beauty they long for. And all this kind of stuff about
我们一直在舔舐伤口。你知道，我们一直在为德雷福斯案件、大型间谍案等等事情而自我撕裂。实际上现在够了。让我们重新站起来。有一本书《今天的年轻人》，出版于1913年。战争。那个词突然获得了一种声望，一个年轻的新词，散发着一种古老的战争本能重新在人们心中激发的吸引力。年轻人在其中看到了他们渴望的所有美。所有这些关于
how brilliant war is, how France has always been a warlike nation. We should stop apologising. So Dominic, what you're saying is that actually it's France that's the militarist power, not Germany. Is that what you're saying? I think they're both militarist powers, actually. But which is more militarist? Well, Pancory brought in a thing called the Three Years' Law, which is three years of military service. And that raised French troop levels equivalent to those of Germany. But remember, Germany has a much bigger population. So France is actually more militarised?
战争是多么辉煌，法国一直是一个好战的国家。我们应该停止道歉。所以多米尼克，你的意思是实际上是法国这个军国主义大国，而不是德国。你是这个意思吗？我认为他们都是军国主义大国，实际上。但哪个更军国主义？好吧，普恩加莱引入了一项名为“三年法”的东西，即三年的兵役。这使法国的军队水平与德国相当。但请记住，德国的人口要多得多。所以法国实际上更军国主义化？
Per capita, France is the most militarized society in Western Europe. Now, listen, they're all relatively militarized societies, right? So I'm not saying that one thing is better than another, but I'm just making the point that the French like their neighbors. Yeah, yeah. I know. The legacy of your failure at art. Castling its shadow over you.
按人均计算，法国是西欧最军国主义化的社会。现在，听着，他们都是相对军国主义化的社会，对吧？所以我不是说一件事比另一件事好，我只是指出法国人喜欢他们的邻居。是的，是的。我知道。你美术失败的遗产。笼罩着你。
I am sticking up for France here. Listen, Tom, if you don't want to take it from me, would you take it from the Belgian ambassador, Baron Guillaume? Not necessarily. The Belgians are notorious for their dislike of France. Well, his name is Guillaume. Is that not enough for you? He wrote back to Brussels and said,
我在这里支持法国。听着，汤姆，如果你不想听我的，你会听比利时大使巴伦·纪尧姆的吗？不一定。比利时人以不喜欢法国而闻名。好吧，他的名字叫纪尧姆。这还不够吗？他写信回布鲁塞尔说，
I'm really worried about the new mood in French politics. Nationalist, jingoistic and chauvinist. The greatest peril for peace in today's Europe. So that's a Belgian. I mean, I always listen to the Belgians. So for Poincaré, that alliance with Russia is incredibly important. And in his book, The Sleepwalkers, Christopher Clarke describes at some length how the French are very worried that the Russians, as they're becoming more and more powerful and more and
我真的很担心法国政治中的新情绪。民族主义、沙文主义和盲目爱国主义。当今欧洲和平的最大危险。所以那是一个比利时人。我的意思是，我总是听比利时人的。所以对于普恩加莱来说，与俄罗斯的同盟极其重要。在他的书《梦游者》中，克里斯托弗·克拉克详细描述了法国人非常担心俄罗斯人，随着他们变得越来越强大和越来越
more industrialized, might one day decide that they don't need the French. I mean, that would be terrible for France. So rather like the Germans and the Austrians, who are sort of always trying to, they're so anxious about their ally that they're doing more and more to kind of appease them. The guiding principle of French policy is like, we bind ourselves to Russia, we lend them money for their railways, we do all this kind of thing. We never want to kind of let them out of our sight, as it were. And the French are very aware that if there is ever to be a war, they really need the Russians in on it. And so the best place for that war to start is the Balkans. So even before 1914, the French and the Russians have explicitly discussed what would
工业化，有一天可能会决定他们不需要法国人了。我的意思是，这对法国来说将是可怕的。所以就像德国人和奥地利人一样，他们总是试图，他们对盟友如此焦虑，以至于他们正在做更多的事情来安抚他们。法国政策的指导原则是，我们与俄罗斯捆绑在一起，我们借钱给他们修铁路，我们做所有这些事情。我们永远不想让他们离开我们的视线。法国人非常清楚，如果真的发生战争，他们真的需要俄罗斯人参与其中。所以那场战争开始的最佳地点是巴尔干半岛。所以甚至在1914年之前，法国人和俄罗斯人就已经明确讨论过
happen if there was a flashpoint in the Balkans. And they've said, we will get stuck in. We will not let you down. We will stand by you. That is the best place. So do the French actively want a war? I know the French covers a broad remit. Does Poincaré, do the people around him, do they actively want a war? Are they looking for a Casus belli? No, I don't think they are. But I think it's maybe not massively dissimilar from the German perspective that they think, you know, they know that there will one day be another war and they want it to be on their
如果巴尔干半岛出现爆发点会发生什么。他们说，我们会介入。我们不会让你失望。我们会支持你。那是最好的地方。所以法国人积极想要战争吗？我知道法国涵盖的范围很广。普恩加莱，他周围的人，他们积极想要战争吗？他们在寻找战争借口吗？不，我不认为他们是。但我认为这可能与德国的观点没有太大区别，他们认为，你知道，他们知道有一天会发生另一场战争，他们希望它按照他们的
terms and to win and to get back Alsace and Lorraine. So again, it's aggression as a form of defence. I think so, yes. Although with the specific aim of getting back their territorial losses. They are revanchist in a way that maybe some of these other empires aren't, because they feel that a part of France has been taken from them. And they're determined, someone like Poincaré is determined to get it back. So do the French High Command look at what's happening in the Balkans and think, brilliant, this is our chance to get back Alsace-Lorraine?
条件进行，并获胜，收复阿尔萨斯和洛林。所以再次强调，这是作为一种防御形式的侵略。我想是的，是的。尽管有收复领土损失的具体目标。他们是复仇主义者，以一种其他帝国可能没有的方式，因为他们觉得法国的一部分被从他们手中夺走了。他们决心，像普恩加莱这样的人决心收复它。所以法国最高统帅部看着巴尔干半岛发生的事情，心想，太棒了，这是我们收复阿尔萨斯-洛林的机会吗？
Or is it more happenstance than that? I think to some degree they do. Christopher Clarke talks of a Balkan trigger. I think it's almost more of a Balkan tripwire, constructed a tripwire across the Danube. They talk about this explicitly. And in the Balkan Wars of 1912, the French had said to the Russians, you know, if you really want to get stuck in, you know where we are. The thing I love about, you've said how everyone behaves according to their national stereotype, is that when the Archduke is assassinated in Sarajevo, actually French public opinion barely pays any attention to it because they're all obsessed by the most incredible sex scandal, aren't they?
还是这比那更偶然？我认为在某种程度上他们是这样想的。克里斯托弗·克拉克谈到了巴尔干触发器。我认为这更像是一个巴尔干绊线，在多瑙河上设置了一条绊线。他们明确谈到了这一点。在1912年的巴尔干战争中，法国人曾对俄罗斯人说，你知道，如果你真的想介入，你知道我们在哪里。我喜欢的一点是，你已经说过每个人都根据他们的民族刻板印象行事，当大公在萨拉热窝遇刺时，实际上法国公众舆论几乎没有关注它，因为他们都被最不可思议的性丑闻迷住了，不是吗？
They are. So a former prime minister called Joseph Caillou, his wife, Henriette, had burst into the offices of Le Figaro and shot the editor, shot him dead, because he had published letters from her husband's mistress. So the trial is going on, you know, in the aftermath. Yeah. And she gets acquitted on the grounds that this is perfectly reasonable behaviour. Yeah, that she'd been humiliated by this editor and therefore she had every right to shoot him dead. This drives Franz Ferdinand off the front pages. So actually, this is an important point. In France, the kind of sense of sympathy,
他们是。所以一位前总理叫约瑟夫·卡约，他的妻子亨丽埃特闯入了《费加罗报》的办公室，枪杀了编辑，把他打死了，因为他发表了她丈夫情妇的信件。所以审判正在进行，你知道，在事后。是的。她被判无罪，理由是这是完全合理的行为。是的，她被这位编辑羞辱了，因此她完全有权枪杀他。这把弗朗茨·斐迪南赶出了头版。所以实际上，这是一个重要的点。在法国，那种同情心，
I mean, the French hate the Austrians anyway, don't they? We're going to be doing Marie Antoinette next month. I mean, the French have no time for the Austrians whatsoever. So there's really very little sympathy in France for Franz Ferdinand. There's far more sympathy in Britain than there is in France because the Caillaux trial drives it off the front pages. And insofar as the Paris Press
我的意思是，法国人反正讨厌奥地利人，不是吗？我们下个月要讲玛丽·安托瓦内特。我的意思是，法国人根本没有时间理会奥地利人。所以法国对弗朗茨·斐迪南几乎没有什么同情心。英国的同情心远比法国多，因为卡约审判把它赶出了头版。而且就巴黎媒体
mentions the Balkans at all, it says, listen, first of all, it is a disgrace that the Viennese papers are stirring things up against Serbia. Poor Serbia, totally blameless. Because Serbia has been a recipient of enormous French loans, hasn't it? Yeah, French loans. And that the Austrian government would use this to make these cruel accusations against Belgrade. Disgraceful. So that is the context for Poincaré to go off to St. Petersburg. He doesn't go on his own. He goes on a boat, as we've described in that lovely reading. And he goes with the prime minister of France, who's just taken over,
提到巴尔干半岛而言，它说，听着，首先，维也纳报纸煽动反对塞尔维亚是一种耻辱。可怜的塞尔维亚，完全无辜。因为塞尔维亚一直是巨额法国贷款的接受者，不是吗？是的，法国贷款。奥地利政府会利用这一点对贝尔格莱德做出这些残酷的指控。可耻。这就是普恩加莱前往圣彼得堡的背景。他不是一个人去的。他坐船去的，正如我们在那段可爱的阅读中所描述的那样。他带着刚刚接任的法国总理，
who's a guy called René Viviani. And Viviani... He's not a warmonger, is he? He's an anti-clerical socialist politician. He's always losing all his important papers. And he looks like... I mean, there's no other way of putting it, I'm afraid. He looks like a cross between Inspector Clouseau
一个叫勒内·维维亚尼的人。维维亚尼……他不是战争贩子，是吗？他是一位反教权的社会主义政治家。他总是丢失所有重要的文件。他看起来像……我的意思是，恐怕没有别的说法了。他看起来像是克鲁索探长
and the café proprietor René in, in the sitcom, Allo, Allo. So again, conforming to stereotype. Yeah. So they arrive on the 20th and 21st of July in St. Petersburg. And right from the beginning, Poincaré takes a very hard line. So there's a big reception for ambassadors. And at that, Poincaré meets the Habsburg ambassador to St Petersburg now of course he has an absolutely tremendous name
和情景喜剧《阿洛，阿洛》中的咖啡馆老板勒内的混合体。所以再次符合刻板印象。是的。所以他们在7月20日和21日抵达圣彼得堡。从一开始，普恩加莱就采取了非常强硬的立场。所以有一个盛大的大使招待会。在那次招待会上，普恩加莱会见了哈布斯堡驻圣彼得堡大使，当然，他有一个绝对惊人的名字
Count Fridges Zapary de Zapa Murazombat e Sisyget I think we'll just call him Count Zapary Edward Habsburg that's a much yeah it's a much simpler name, isn't it? Pankaj says to this guy, to this ambassador, yeah, I'm very sorry about Franz Ferdinand, what a terrible shame that was. And then says, are you thinking of forging documents to frame the Serbs? Is that what you're thinking of doing? Because don't even think about it. And the ambassador is really shocked by this. And then Pankaj says to him, let me remind you,
弗里德里希·萨帕里·德·扎帕·穆拉宗巴特·埃·西西格特伯爵，我想我们还是叫他萨帕里伯爵吧，爱德华·哈布斯堡，那是一个更……是的，这是一个更简单的名字，不是吗？普恩加莱对这个人说，对这位大使说，是的，我对弗朗茨·斐迪南感到非常遗憾，那真是太可惜了。然后说，你在考虑伪造文件来陷害塞尔维亚人吗？这就是你在考虑做的事情吗？因为想都别想。大使对此感到非常震惊。然后普恩加莱对他说，让我提醒你，
Serbia has friends and they are watching. And the ambassador actually writes back to Vienna and says, you know, I was really upset by this. I was really shocked that the president of France would be so tactless and insensitive and confrontational when he's supposed to be offering his condolences. And poor old Viviani. I mean, he's getting more and more stressed by all this, isn't he? Yeah. The warmongering of Poincaré. He is. He basically has a breakdown.
塞尔维亚有朋友，他们正在看着。大使实际上写信回维也纳说，你知道，我对此感到非常不安。我真的很震惊，法国总统在应该表示慰问时竟然如此缺乏机智、麻木不仁和对抗性。可怜的维维亚尼。我的意思是，他越来越紧张了，不是吗？是的。普恩加莱的战争贩子行为。他是。他基本上崩溃了。
So the next day, the 22nd of July, he's seen lurking around. There's a big sort of marquee, and he's seen outside the marquee, and I quote, Gibbering. Muttering, grumbling, swearing loudly, and generally drawing attention to himself. So Viviani has his breakdown. Poincaré says says to him get a grip of yourself man go and have the doctor see you and i think historians generally think this is because poincaré is adopted it's just as well because there's a banquet that evening a military gala and at that there are these two montenegrin princesses yes because what this story has missed so far is montenegrin princesses yes because what this story has missed so far
所以第二天，7月22日，他被看到潜伏在周围。有一个很大的帐篷，他被看到在帐篷外面，我引用，胡言乱语。喃喃自语，抱怨，大声咒骂，通常引起人们对他的注意。所以维维亚尼崩溃了。普恩加莱对他说，振作起来，伙计，让医生看看你，我认为历史学家通常认为这是因为普恩加莱采取了……这很好，因为那天晚上有一个宴会，一个军事晚会，在那次宴会上，有两位黑山公主，是的，因为这个故事到目前为止错过了黑山公主，是的，因为这个故事到目前为止错过了
is montenegrin princesses and they come in late but they come in hard don't they they do come in hard so montenegro of course very close to serbia serbia's kind of sister kingdom in the bulgans and these two montenegrin princesses they are married to sort of cousins of the czar they're called anastasia and milica and they are the kind of bells of the ball. And they are shouting at this banquet to Poincaré. Have a war. Crack on. Get Alsace-Lorraine back.
黑山公主，她们来晚了，但她们来势汹汹，不是吗？她们确实来势汹汹。所以黑山当然离塞尔维亚很近，塞尔维亚是巴尔干半岛的姐妹王国，这两位黑山公主，她们嫁给了沙皇的表亲，她们叫阿纳斯塔西娅和米利卡，她们是舞会上的焦点。她们在宴会上对普恩加莱大喊大叫。打仗吧。加油。收复阿尔萨斯-洛林。
There's going to be a war. There'll be nothing left of Austria. You're going to get back Alsace-Lorraine. We will meet in Berlin. And all this kind of thing. And a lot of people at this, French officials, not Poincaré himself, but a lot of French officials are quite perturbed by this. Embarrassed.
会有战争的。奥地利将不复存在。你会收复阿尔萨斯-洛林。我们将在柏林会面。所有这些事情。很多人，法国官员，不是普恩加莱本人，但很多法国官员对此感到相当不安。尴尬。
Yeah, it's embarrassing anyway the summit has gone as well as Pankow wanted basically he's cemented the alliance with Russia they've agreed you know
是的，这很尴尬，总之峰会进行得和普恩加莱想要的一样好，基本上他巩固了与俄罗斯的同盟，他们同意，你知道
we will work really hard to bring Britain further and further deeper into our alliance we need to bind Britain to us and this business in the Balkans
我们将非常努力地让英国进一步深入我们的同盟，我们需要把英国捆绑在我们身边，而巴尔干半岛的这件事
if it comes to anything a hard line is the only way to deal with these teutons dominic you say everything goes brilliantly but there is one fly in the ointment isn't there which is i mean terrible for a french president that the dinner on board his ship the fros is an absolute disaster shambles the soup course is late the Russians don't like any of the court dishes a huge embarrassment
如果有什么结果，强硬路线是处理这些条顿人的唯一方法。多米尼克，你说一切都很顺利，但有一个瑕疵，不是吗？我的意思是，对于法国总统来说，他船上的晚餐绝对是一场灾难，混乱不堪，汤菜上晚了，俄罗斯人不喜欢任何宫廷菜肴，非常尴尬。
I think this is the Russian salad issue again personally I tried to track down the menu for this and I couldn't find it but there's no doubt in my mind
我个人认为这又是俄罗斯沙拉的问题，我试着去查了这份菜单，但没找到，不过我毫不怀疑
they would have served that Russian salad borscht and nobody likes Russian salad it's a terrible thing do you think they would have tried to put a
他们肯定供应了那道俄罗斯沙拉罗宋汤，而且没人喜欢俄罗斯沙拉，那东西太难吃了，你觉得他们会尝试给罗宋汤加点
French spin on borscht or something like that they would have done is borscht Russian I can't remember borscht is Russian yeah it pours the rain and they have a marquee and the marquee falls down and Poincaré spin on Borscht or something like that? They would have done. Is Borscht Russian? I can't remember. Borscht is Russian. Yeah.
法式风味之类的吗？他们肯定会这么做。罗宋汤是俄罗斯的吗？我不记得了。罗宋汤是俄罗斯的，对，下着雨，他们有个大帐篷，帐篷塌了，而普恩加莱给罗宋汤加了点法式风味之类的吗？他们肯定会这么做。罗宋汤是俄罗斯的吗？我不记得了。罗宋汤是俄罗斯的。对。
It pours the rain and they have a marquee and the marquee falls down. And Poincaré is absolutely furious. He also has another row with Viviani because they need to publish basically a press release, a communique. And Viviani says, the communique cannot be too hardline about the Balkans.
雨下得很大，他们有个大帐篷，帐篷塌了。普恩加莱非常愤怒。他和维维亚尼又吵了一架，因为他们基本上需要发布一份新闻稿，一份公报。维维亚尼说，公报在巴尔干问题上不能太强硬。
And he ends up kind of slightly being overruled. Poincaré, basically, you don't know what you're talking about. You don't know anything about foreign affairs. Shut up. So that night, the 23rd of July, they set sail back on their ship. Poincaré is like, great. We're on the same page, us and the Russians. Whatever happens will happen. But we're pretty confident that if the Austrians do do something, we will call their bluff and get them to back down because only a fool would invite a world war against France and Russia combined. And of course, the one thing they have not considered is exactly the same thing that the Austrians have not considered, which is, what if the other side
结果他最终还是稍微被否决了。普恩加莱基本上说，你根本不知道自己在说什么。你对外交事务一窍不通。闭嘴。所以那天晚上，7月23日，他们乘船启程回国。普恩加莱心想，太好了。我们和俄国人达成共识了。无论发生什么都会发生。但我们非常有信心，如果奥地利人真的采取行动，我们会揭穿他们的虚张声势，让他们退缩，因为只有傻瓜才会招致一场针对法国和俄国联合起来的世界大战。当然，他们唯一没考虑到的，正是奥地利人也没考虑到的，那就是，如果对方
don't back down? What if your calculations are wrong? What happens next? And we'll find out, Tom, after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
不退缩怎么办？如果你们的算盘打错了怎么办？接下来会发生什么？汤姆，休息之后我们再揭晓。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《余下皆娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history and domin, I think it's fair to say that the doomsday clock is ticking down, isn't it? Never have those storm clouds of war. Storm clouds of war are gathering because even as the French president and poor old Viviani, who's been having breakdowns left, right and centre, are sailing out of Kronstadt Harbour
在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com，也就是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《余下皆历史》，多米尼克，我觉得可以说末日时钟正在倒计时，对吧？战争的乌云从未如此。战争的乌云正在聚集，因为就在法国总统和可怜的维维亚尼——他一直在崩溃边缘徘徊——驶离喀琅施塔得港
to go back to France, the Austrians have been getting their ultimatum ready. Yeah. And sure enough, on Thursday, the 23rd of July, the ultimatum is delivered to the Serbs. It is exactly. And so it's going to be delivered by the Austrian ambassador, as is the law with the Austrian diplomatic service. He has a splendid name.
准备回法国时，奥地利人已经准备好了他们的最后通牒。是的。果然，在7月23日星期四，最后通牒被送达塞尔维亚人手中。确实如此。所以它将由奥地利大使送达，这是奥地利外交部的惯例。他有一个响亮的名字。
He is Vladimir Rudolf Karl Freiherr Giesel von Gieslingen. And at six o'clock, so it's at six o'clock because Poincaré and Viviani have left on their ship from Kronstadt. He's waited till they've left. And it's enough time so that the Russians will struggle to communicate with the French ship. That's the whole point of their plan. Another complication with the ultimatum, the Serbs are having an election campaign. So the prime minister, Nikola Pasic, is away on the campaign trail. So when Gisela, the Austrian ambassador, turns up to deliver the ultimatum, the only person
他是弗拉基米尔·鲁道夫·卡尔·弗赖赫尔·吉塞尔·冯·吉斯林根。在六点钟，之所以是六点钟，是因为普恩加莱和维维亚尼已经乘船离开了喀琅施塔得。他等到他们离开才行动。这留出了足够的时间，让俄国人难以与法国船只取得联系。这就是他们计划的全部目的。最后通牒的另一个复杂之处在于，塞尔维亚人正在进行竞选活动。所以总理尼古拉·帕希奇正在竞选途中。因此，当奥地利大使吉塞尔出现递交最后通牒时，唯一在场的人
there is the finance minister, who's a very large man, a chain-smoking man, very unhealthy, I think it's fair to say. And he doesn't speak any French, which is the language of diplomacy, and so they have to drag in somebody to act as a translator. And when the finance minister is given the ultimatum, he basically doesn't want to pick it up because he doesn't want to be tainted by it, like it's radioactive. And Giesel says to him, don't hang around.
是财政部长，一个身材魁梧、烟不离手、身体状况很差的人，我觉得这么说很公平。他不会说法语，而法语是外交语言，所以他们不得不拉来一个人充当翻译。当财政部长拿到最后通牒时，他基本上不想接手，因为他不想被它玷污，就像它有放射性一样。吉塞尔对他说，别磨蹭。
There's a 48-hour deadline. And he says, oh, we'll need much more time. We're in the middle of an election. And Giesel, slightly patronisingly, sort of says, do you not have railways? Do you not have telegraphs in this country? 48 hours is more than enough time. Because if you don't answer, I will sever diplomatic relations and leave Belgrade immediately. And then he sort of bows and goes out. Clicks his heels, I hope.
有48小时的最后期限。他说，哦，我们需要更多时间。我们正处于选举期间。吉塞尔带着一点居高临下的态度说，你们国家没有铁路吗？没有电报吗？48小时绰绰有余。因为如果你不答复，我将断绝外交关系并立即离开贝尔格莱德。然后他鞠了个躬就出去了。我希望他当时脚后跟并拢响亮地磕了一下。
I would like to think so. So the Serbian minister's still in the capital. They open the ultimatum and they finally see this thing that the Austrians have been working on. So here is the ultimatum. It starts off by saying, for years you have tolerated societies and groups that have sponsored acts of terrorism, outrages and murders. And they're not wrong.
我也希望如此。所以塞尔维亚部长还在首都。他们打开了最后通牒，终于看到了奥地利人一直在准备的东西。这就是最后通牒。开头写着，多年来你们容忍了那些资助恐怖主义、暴行和谋杀的社团和组织。他们没说错。
Yeah, they're not wrong. Yeah, they're not wrong. They're not wrong at all. Our investigations, which of course have been continuing in Sarajevo all this time, our investigations have revealed that the men who carried out this murder were groomed, recruited in Belgrade, and they were helped over the border by your frontier service officials. Again, not wrong. Not wrong at all.
是的，他们没说错。是的，他们一点也没说错。我们的调查——当然，这段时间一直在萨拉热窝进行——我们的调查显示，实施这次谋杀的人是在贝尔格莱德被培养、招募的，并且在你们边境服务人员的帮助下越过了边境。同样，没说错。一点也没错。
But they haven't tracked down the Black Hand, have they? No, they haven't. This is the amazing thing. That at this point, the Austrians, they suspect that there are links to some of these kind of networks in Belgrade. But they haven't actually got that far. They don't actually know the half of it. They haven't got APIS, for example.
但他们还没查到“黑手党”，对吧？不，他们没有。这才是最神奇的地方。在这一点上，奥地利人怀疑贝尔格莱德存在一些这类网络，但他们实际上还没查到那么深。他们根本不知道内幕的一半。例如，他们还没抓到阿皮斯。
They've got the mastermind behind the plot. So there are 10 demands in the ultimatum. and most of them we can deal with very quickly. They are things like, you must suppress such and such a nationalist group, such and such an ultra-nationalist periodical. Then they mention, you must act against these people in the army, these people on the border. They have tracked down the two men who are most involved in grooming and recruiting and arming the gang. That is a guy, if you listen to the Sarajevo series, a guy called Major Tankasic and a guy called Milan Siganovich. So the Austrians have them. They say, we know their names. You must act against these two men.
他们抓到了阴谋背后的主谋。所以最后通牒里有10项要求，大部分我们可以很快处理。比如，你们必须取缔某某民族主义团体，某某极端民族主义期刊。然后他们提到，你们必须对军队里的这些人、边境上的那些人采取行动。他们已经追踪到了那两个在培养、招募和武装团伙方面参与最深的人。那是一个人，如果你听了萨拉热窝系列，一个叫坦卡西奇少校的人和一个叫米兰·西加诺维奇的人。所以奥地利人掌握了他们。他们说，我们知道他们的名字。你们必须对这两个人采取行动。
And Dominic, this is very familiar to people who've lived through recent American wars. Yeah. You know, demands to the Taliban that they surrender as Ahmad bin Laden, that kind of thing. Yeah. I think that's the obvious parallel that will have struck a lot of people. Yeah. Now, there are two really inflammatory points there in the ultimatum, points five and six. Point five says, to suppress the subversive ultra-nationalist movements you must accept
多米尼克，这对经历过近期美国战争的人来说非常熟悉。是的。你知道，要求塔利班交出奥萨马·本·拉登之类的。是的。我认为这是很多人都会想到的明显类比。是的。现在，最后通牒中有两个非常煽动性的点，即第五点和第六点。第五点说，为了取缔颠覆性的极端民族主义运动，你们必须接受
our collaboration on your soil. So in other words we will come and help you suppress these groups whether you like it or not. And point six, you must allow our investigators into Belgrade
我们在你们领土上的合作。换句话说，无论你们喜不喜欢，我们都会来帮助你们取缔这些团体。第六点，你们必须允许我们的调查人员进入贝尔格莱德
to take part in the investigations into the murder of Franz Ferdinand and Sophie. And that is a direct assault on Serbian sovereignty. It absolutely is. Now, Winston Churchill said of this document, the most insolent document of its kind ever devised. Christopher Clarke points out that actually it's not the most insolent such document in Serbian history because NATO's ultimatum in 1999 over Kosovo was a much greater
参与对弗朗茨·斐迪南和索菲谋杀案的调查。这是对塞尔维亚主权的直接攻击。绝对是。温斯顿·丘吉尔曾评价这份文件为“同类文件中最傲慢的一份”。克里斯托弗·克拉克指出，实际上它并不是塞尔维亚历史上最傲慢的文件，因为1999年北约就科索沃问题发出的最后通牒是对
intrusion in Serbian sovereignty. The thing for Serbia is of course if they allowed in Austro-Hungarian investigators those investigators would find all kinds of things I mean imagine if they opened the briefcase of that bloke who's got the breast of the queen in it Right, exactly.
塞尔维亚主权更大的侵犯。对塞尔维亚来说，问题在于如果他们允许奥匈帝国的调查人员进入，那些调查人员会发现各种各样的东西，想象一下如果他们打开那个装着王后胸部的家伙的公文包，对吧，没错。
What's this? Exactly. There's a lot of stuff in basements. There's a lot of dodgy stuff. There's a lot of stuff. I mean, there's all these blokes who've been going and swearing oaths in front of skulls and stuff. If the Austrians find all that, it's going to be hard to justify that in the Council of Europe, isn't it? I mean, so when the Serbians see this ultimatum, they're very shocked.
这是什么？没错。地下室里有很多东西。有很多见不得人的东西。有很多东西。我的意思是，有那么多家伙去对着骷髅发誓之类的。如果奥地利人发现了这一切，在欧洲理事会里就很难辩解了，不是吗？所以当塞尔维亚人看到这份最后通牒时，他们非常震惊。
So they had not seen this coming? Well, it's complicated. I think some of them suspected it was coming, but I don't. I think they kind of hoped. They pretended it wasn't coming. It's like you're waiting for bad news and you sort of tell yourself. Because Pasic, the prime minister, I mean, he's clearly thrown into a funk, isn't he?
所以他们没预料到这一点？嗯，这很复杂。我想他们中有些人怀疑它会来，但我不知道。我想他们有点希望。他们假装它不会来。就像你在等待坏消息，然后你告诉自己。因为帕希奇，那位总理，他显然陷入了恐慌，不是吗？
Because he's out on the campaign trail and he suddenly announces he's going to have a holiday in Thessaloniki. Well, he doesn't announce. He says to... He just goes. He's literally been on the campaign trail that day shaking hands.
因为他正在竞选途中，突然宣布要去塞萨洛尼基度假。嗯，他没有宣布。他只是对……他直接走了。那天他还在竞选途中握手。
Yeah. And then he says to his... One of his aides or something says, there's this ultimatum in Belgrade. He says, do you know what? Actually, I think we should go. Let's have a weekend break. Yeah.
是的。然后他对他的……他的助手还是谁说，贝尔格莱德有这份最后通牒。他说，你知道吗？其实，我觉得我们应该走。去度个周末吧。是的。
And some people think he had a breakdown. He has form on this, doesn't he? Because earlier when the king and queen were murdered and hacked to pieces by all the assassins, he'd scarpered off to the Adriatic coast. So obviously his instinct in a crisis is to head off to a resort. Go to a resort. I mean, why wouldn't you? Yeah, he's about to go to Thessaloniki and basically his train has to be stopped and a station master gives him a note from the regent, Alexander, that says, this is ultimatum in Belgrade. You can't run away. You have to go back and deal with it. So he goes back and at dawn the next day, Friday the 24th, remember, 48-hour timeline.
有些人认为他崩溃了。他有前科，不是吗？因为早些时候当国王和王后被刺客谋杀并砍成碎片时，他就溜到了亚得里亚海沿岸。所以显然他在危机中的本能就是去度假胜地。去度假胜地。我的意思是，为什么不呢？是的，他正要前往塞萨洛尼基，基本上他的火车不得不停下来，车站站长给了他一张摄政王亚历山大写的便条，上面写着，这是贝尔格莱德的最后通牒。你不能逃跑。你必须回去处理它。所以他回去了，第二天黎明，24日星期五，记住，48小时的时间线。
Yeah, so the clock really is ticking. Genuinely, the clock is ticking. He meets his cabinet at dawn on the Friday, so it's going to expire Saturday evening. Friday morning, they meet and they are all very, very anxious and dejected is the eyewitness account. The plan is, well, we'll ask for more time because that will give other people a chance to get stuck in and, you well, we'll ask for more time because that will give other people
是的，所以时钟确实在滴答作响。真的，时钟在滴答作响。他在周五黎明会见了内阁，所以它将在周六晚上到期。周五早上，他们会面了，据目击者描述，他们都非常、非常焦虑和沮丧。计划是，好吧，我们会要求更多时间，因为那会给其他人机会介入，而且你，好吧，我们会要求更多时间，因为那会给其他人
a chance to get stuck in and we'll play for time. But they know that the Austrians really won't give them more time. So what are they going to do? There are two schools of thought on this among historians. Thomas Otte, for example, says,
机会介入，我们会争取时间。但他们知道奥地利人真的不会给他们更多时间。那么他们要做什么呢？历史学家对此有两种看法。例如，托马斯·奥特说，
the Serbians could never have accepted this note. The intrusion on their sovereignty was too great and it would be disastrous for them given they've got all the stuff hanging around in the basements or whatever. Chris Clark says, there's some evidence actually the Serbs, some of them were tempted to accept. A historian called Luigi Albertini interviewed a lot of the Serbian ministers and Serbian officials and some of them said, you know, at first our instinct was to just say, fine. Surely, I mean, ultimately it depends on whether Serbia can get support for its position
塞尔维亚人永远不可能接受这份照会。对他们主权的侵犯太大了，而且考虑到他们地下室里藏着的所有东西，这对他们来说将是灾难性的。克里斯·克拉克说，实际上有一些证据表明塞尔维亚人，他们中有些人曾想过接受。一位名叫路易吉·阿尔贝蒂尼的历史学家采访了许多塞尔维亚部长和官员，有些人说，你知道，起初我们的本能就是说，好吧。当然，我的意思是，最终这取决于塞尔维亚能否为其立场获得支持
against Austria, which basically means Russia. Yes, it does. Because if Russia comes in behind them, then obviously that completely changes the terms of their calculations. It does indeed. And this is why I think any account of the origins of the First World War that doesn't give Russia a huge, huge part in this is missing something, because everything depends now upon how Russia reacts. Now, just after the France has left St. Petersburg, they get the news in Russia of the ultimatum. They have known that something is coming, so I don't think they are totally surprised because of their intelligence has warned them there is something on the way.
对抗奥地利，这基本上意味着俄国。是的，确实如此。因为如果俄国支持他们，那么这显然完全改变了他们计算的条件。确实如此。这就是为什么我认为任何不给俄国在其中分配巨大角色的第一次世界大战起源的叙述都是缺失的，因为现在一切都取决于俄国的反应。现在，就在法国离开圣彼得堡后，他们在俄国收到了最后通牒的消息。他们知道有什么事情要发生，所以我认为他们并不完全感到惊讶，因为他们的情报已经警告他们有事情要来了。
But Sassanoff, this foreign minister, looks like a bank manager, a nice beard, very kind man by all accounts. He opens this and he says, C'est la guerre européenne. It's a European war. And he rings the Tsar. It's the first, I believe,
但萨佐诺夫，这位外交部长，看起来像个银行经理，留着漂亮的胡子，据说是位非常善良的人。他打开这份文件说，C'est la guerre européenne（这是欧洲战争）。他给沙皇打了电话。我相信这是
one of the first times the Tsar had ever used a telephone. Really? So Sitting Bull was more familiar with the telephone than the Tsar. The telephone than the Tsar. It's the first, I believe, one of the first times the Tsar had ever used a telephone. Really? So Sitting Bull was more familiar with the telephone than the Tsar. The Tsar would look down on the telephone as a democratic intrusion on Russia's traditions. And Sazanov says to the Tsar, oh, this is terrible. The Austrians are clearly itching for war. He blames the Germans, of course. They always see the Austrians merely as sort of puppets of Germany, which is not quite right. The Tsar says, I'm not sure about this because Willi, my cousin, is a lovely man.
沙皇第一次使用电话。真的吗？所以坐牛比沙皇更熟悉电话。电话比沙皇。我相信这是沙皇第一次使用电话。真的吗？所以坐牛比沙皇更熟悉电话。电话比沙皇。沙皇会看不起电话，认为这是对俄国传统的民主侵犯。萨佐诺夫对沙皇说，哦，这太可怕了。奥地利人显然渴望战争。他当然责怪德国人。他们总是把奥地利人仅仅看作是德国的傀儡，这并不完全正确。沙皇说，我不确定这一点，因为威利，我的表弟，是个可爱的人。
Well, they just had a summit, hadn't they? Yeah. Just a few months before and got on tremendously well. Yeah. And I think the Tsar makes a good point, which is, he says, Willi leads a country that, you know, no one likes the Germans, but they're very rich. They're very successful. Everything's going well for them. Why would they risk everything with the world war? Mad.
嗯，他们刚举行过峰会，不是吗？是的。就在几个月前，相处得非常好。是的。而且我认为沙皇说得有道理，他说，威利领导的国家，你知道，没人喜欢德国人，但他们非常富有。他们非常成功。一切对他们来说都很顺利。他们为什么要用世界大战来冒险呢？疯了。
Yeah, good point. They don't want a world war. But Sassanoff says, is adamant. He believes his own propaganda because he meets the Austrian ambassador and he says to him that day, what are you doing? You're setting fire to Europe. This is all because the German papers have egged you on. That's not really true. They've not been egged on by the Germans.
是的，有道理。他们不想要世界大战。但萨佐诺夫很坚定。他相信自己的宣传，因为他那天会见了奥地利大使，并对他说，你在做什么？你在点燃欧洲。这全是因为德国报纸怂恿你们。那不是真的。他们并没有被德国人怂恿。
They've wanted to do it themselves. And then now we can bring on Tom, the great person in this story that we've been looking forward to. Yes. So you began with him. The second best French ambassador in this story, Maurice Pallielogue. And alert listeners with an interest in Byzantine history may remember that the final ruling dynasty in Constantinople are the Paliologs. And Maurice Paliolog claims to be descended from them, doesn't he? He does. I don't want to give the game away right away, but maybe I'll just go for it. I think Maurice Paliolog is a terrible person, Tom. He's like a man from a casting agency who supplied a ridiculous Frenchman.
他们是自己想这么做的。现在我们可以请出汤姆了，这个故事中我们一直期待的伟大人物。是的。所以你从他开始。这个故事中第二好的法国大使，莫里斯·帕莱奥洛格。对拜占庭历史感兴趣的敏锐听众可能记得，君士坦丁堡最后的统治王朝是帕莱奥洛格王朝。而莫里斯·帕莱奥洛格声称是他们的后裔，不是吗？他是。我不想马上剧透，但也许我就直说了。我觉得莫里斯·帕莱奥洛格是个糟糕的人，汤姆。他就像一个选角公司派来的荒谬的法国人。
Well, although he's the son of Greek and, what is it, Romanian? Belgian? I can't remember. Belgian. Yeah, that Greco-Belgian combination was so dangerous in history. So in a way, he's kind of plus français que les français. He is. He's exactly that.
嗯，虽然他是希腊人和，是什么，罗马尼亚人？比利时人？我不记得了。比利时人。是的，那种希腊-比利时组合在历史上太危险了。所以从某种意义上说，他有点“比法国人更法国”。他是。他正是那样。
He's maybe acting the Frenchman to a hilarious pitch. He is. That's exactly what he's doing. He's a dandy. He's exactly that. He's maybe acting the Frenchman to a hilarious pitch. He is. That's exactly what he's doing. He's a dandy. He's a womaniser. He's brought his own chefs from Paris. He's also a novelist, isn't he? He is. Sir George Buchanan, who's his British colleague in Russia, said of him, his vivid imagination is apt to run away with him and disposes him to take a fanciful and exaggerated view of political questions. And I would posit that in a highly combustible situation that might result in a European war, that's exactly the kind of man you want to be running the policy of a key participant. Well, the thing is, you see, Poincaré and Viviani are at sea. So it's down to Paléologue
他可能把法国人演到了滑稽的地步。他是。他正是这么做的。他是个花花公子。他是个女人杀手。他从巴黎带来了自己的厨师。他也是个小说家，不是吗？他是。乔治·布坎南爵士，他在俄国的英国同事，评价他说，他生动的想象力容易让他失控，并使他倾向于对政治问题采取异想天开和夸张的看法。我认为在一个可能导致欧洲战争的高度易燃的情况下，这正是你想要负责关键参与者政策的那种人。嗯，问题是，你看，普恩加莱和维维亚尼在海上。所以这取决于帕莱奥洛格
to deal with the Russians, right? And Palaeolog, as you said, he's a novelist, not just in the realm of traditional fiction, but also in the realm of diplomacy. Because when he goes to meetings with the Tsar, he will often write the report
去应付俄国人，对吧？而帕莱奥洛格，正如你所说，他是个小说家，不仅在传统小说的领域，也在外交领域。因为当他去和沙皇开会时，他经常会
on the meeting before he's gone to the meeting to send it home. But it saves time, doesn't it? Yeah, it saves time. It tells Paris what they want to hear. It's like, you know, people who write up the football match
在去开会之前就写好会议报告寄回国内。但这节省时间，不是吗？是的，节省时间。它告诉巴黎他们想听的内容。就像，你知道，那些在终场哨响前就写好足球比赛报道的人。
before the final whistle. Exactly. And the thing is, everybody has said in the French foreign ministry, Paléologue is a terrible man. Why would you give Paléologue this job? He's a complete loose cannon. And of course, the answer is,
没错。问题是，法国外交部的每个人都说，帕莱奥洛格是个糟糕的人。你为什么要给帕莱奥洛格这份工作？他是个完全不受控制的疯子。当然，答案是，
it's not just in Britain that this happens, Tom. I'm pleased to say, he had been to school with Poincaré. So President Poincaré said, my old schoolmate, Maurice Paléologue, quite a character. Eye for the ladies and loves a chef. So at this meeting, Sazonoff and Paliolog. Sazonoff says, what are we going to do? Paliolog just eggs him on. He never, ever, ever says to Sazonoff,
这不仅仅发生在英国，汤姆。我很高兴地说，他和普恩加莱是校友。所以普恩加莱总统说，我的老同学，莫里斯·帕莱奥洛格，真是个有个性的人。对女士有眼光，还热爱厨师。所以在这个会议上，萨佐诺夫和帕莱奥洛格。萨佐诺夫说，我们该怎么办？帕莱奥洛格只是怂恿他。他从来、从来、从来没有对萨佐诺夫说，
let's slow down a minute. We don't want a world war. He says, no, no, no, we must be hard on the Germans. The Germans and the Austrians are terrible people. We should take a hard line because the only line they understand, you stand up to a bully and all this sort of stuff. So Sazonov has confirmed he's been encouraged in his existing assumption, which is a hard line is the only possible line to take. And so that afternoon, he goes to an absolutely vital and crucial meeting of the Council of Ministers in Russia. And he says, listen, guys, we have appeased the Austrians and the Germans for too long. We have a historic mission in the Balkans.
让我们慢一点。我们不想要世界大战。他说，不，不，不，我们必须对德国人强硬。德国人和奥地利人是可怕的人。我们应该采取强硬路线，因为这是他们唯一能理解的路线，你站出来对抗恶霸之类的。所以萨佐诺夫确认他受到了现有假设的鼓励，即强硬路线是唯一可能的路线。所以那天下午，他去参加了俄国部长会议的一次绝对重要和关键的会议。他说，听着，伙计们，我们安抚奥地利人和德国人太久了。我们在巴尔干地区有历史使命。
And if we back down now, we will lose all our prestige, all our authority forever. We will no longer be a great power. Which is exactly what the Austrians are saying. Of course. Both of them are saying exactly the same. Yes, exactly. This defensive aggression. So the question for me, actually, that has often puzzled me about this story is,
如果我们现在退缩，我们将永远失去所有的威望和权威。我们将不再是一个大国。这正是奥地利人所说的。当然。他们俩说的完全一样。是的，没错。这种防御性的侵略。所以对我来说，实际上在这个故事中一直困扰我的问题是，
I always understood why the Austrians cared. I mean, it's their heir that's been murdered, and they think it's their integrity of their empire that's at stake. What had always puzzled me was why the Russians cared. I mean, Serbia is a long way from Russia. And actually, it was only in the last few weeks while reading about this that I finally understood. The Russians care a lot about the Straits and access to the Straits because it's really, really important for them diplomatically and economically. They care a bit, I suppose, about Slav brotherhood and that sort of thing. Yeah, orthodoxy and all that. But the key thing is, from their perspective, they have backed down twice already in the last five or six years in the Balkans
我一直理解为什么奥地利人关心。我的意思是，被谋杀的是他们的继承人，他们认为这是他们帝国完整性的问题。一直困扰我的是为什么俄国人关心。我的意思是，塞尔维亚离俄国很远。实际上，只是在过去几周阅读相关资料时，我才终于明白。俄国人非常关心海峡以及进入海峡的通道，因为这对他们来说在外交和经济上真的、非常重要。我想他们也关心一点斯拉夫兄弟情谊之类的东西。是的，东正教等等。但关键是，从他们的角度来看，他们在过去五六年里在巴尔干地区已经退缩了两次
over Bosnia, the annexation of Bosnia and then in the balkan wars about whether or not serbia would be allowed to occupy albania and as they see it the austrians are just asking too much to ask them to back down three times in five years so although i personally can completely understand why the austrians acted as they did it has to be said they are making a hell of an ask, as it were. A big ask. A big ask. It's a very big ask. It's basically saying to the Russians, yet again, you must concede to us on this. And at a time when the Russians are worried about the Ottomans getting all their dreadnoughts.
关于波斯尼亚，波斯尼亚的吞并，然后在巴尔干战争中关于塞尔维亚是否被允许占领阿尔巴尼亚，正如他们所见，奥地利人要求他们五年内退缩三次，这要求实在太多了。虽然我个人完全能理解奥地利人为什么那样做，但必须说，他们提出的要求太高了。一个大要求。一个大要求。这是一个非常大的要求。这基本上是在对俄国人说，再一次，你们必须在这件事上向我们让步。而且是在俄国人担心奥斯曼人获得所有无畏舰的时候。
Exactly. And will they be able to keep the straits open and all that kind of thing? Now, you might think, come on, can the two of them get together and sort this out? But you made this point, I think, Tom, in the last episode. Yeah. They don't have email. They can't talk on the phone. Everything has to be done through intermediaries like Maurice Paliog. And he's just making stuff up. Yeah. Ambassadors. Ambassadors who will put their own spin on things. And, you know, there are allies. There's real Chinese whispers. It's hard for them actually to get together and talk about it,
没错。他们还能保持海峡畅通吗？等等。现在，你可能会想，拜托，他们俩不能坐下来解决这个问题吗？但汤姆，我想你在上一集提到了这一点。是的。他们没有电子邮件。他们不能打电话。一切都必须通过像莫里斯·帕莱奥洛格这样的中间人来完成。而他只是在编造东西。是的。大使。大使们会把自己的想法强加给事情。而且，你知道，他们是盟友。这是真正的“传话游戏”。他们实际上很难坐下来谈论这件事，
even if they wanted to. Yeah. And both sides think time is running out. We are embattled. The others are malevolent and plotting against us. Because the Russians actually overestimate Austrian military prowess, don't they? Well, I mean, I think the Austrians overrate Austrian military prowess.
即使他们想谈。是的。而且双方都认为时间不多了。我们处于困境。其他人是恶意的，正在密谋反对我们。因为俄国人实际上高估了奥地利的军事实力，不是吗？嗯，我的意思是，我认为奥地利人高估了奥地利的军事实力。
Right. But the Russians, I mean, the Russians, even though they have these massive forces and are relatively confident, they're still, you know, they don't want to be caught out. They don't want to have a mobilising empire on their doorstep. Do you know, Tom, I was thinking about this in the break between recording these two episodes that we've recorded this morning. I was thinking about what made this different from Napoleonic Wars or something. And I guess part of it is that you can make a mistake and embark on the Nine Years' War or the Seven Years' War or something, and what's going to happen? You'll lose Menorca. The results will not necessarily be apocalyptic for you if it goes against you. But one reason that they are all so
没错。但俄国人，我的意思是，俄国人，尽管他们拥有庞大的军队并且相对自信，但他们仍然，你知道，他们不想被抓住把柄。他们不想在家门口有一个动员的帝国。你知道吗，汤姆，我在录制今天早上这两集之间的休息时间里一直在想这个问题。我在想是什么让这与拿破仑战争或其他战争不同。我想部分原因是你可以犯错并开始九年战争或七年战争之类的，会发生什么？你会失去梅诺卡岛。如果结果对你不利，不一定会是灾难性的。但他们都如此
frightened, I think, is because they know with industrialized total warfare, the stakes are so high. Yeah. And if you get this wrong, it's not, you know, you'll lose a couple of provinces. If you get this wrong, you could lose everything. Yeah. Your society could cease to exist. And I think that heightens the sense of urgency for them.
害怕的一个原因，我认为，是因为他们知道在工业化全面战争中，赌注太高了。是的。如果你搞错了，不是说，你知道，你会失去几个省。如果你搞错了，你可能会失去一切。是的。你的社会可能会不复存在。我认为这加剧了他们的紧迫感。
You cannot allow your opponents to get a head start. And so it's obvious that Austria is going to have to mobilize if it's going to have a crack at Serbia. And Austria is a hostile power on your doorstep if you're Russian. So that then implies, well, we'd better start thinking about mobilization. Especially because you are slow. If you're Russian, you are slow. You have the vast army, you have vast territory, you have to bring in people from a long distance. So that night, the 24th, 25th, they've sent a message to Serbia via the Serbian ambassador. They've said, you can't accept this ultimatum.
你不能让你的对手抢占先机。所以很明显，如果奥地利要对塞尔维亚动手，它就必须动员。如果你是俄国人，奥地利是一个家门口的敌对势力。所以这意味着，好吧，我们最好开始考虑动员。特别是如果你很慢的话。如果你是俄国人，你很慢。你有庞大的军队，你有广阔的领土，你必须从很远的地方调人。所以那天晚上，24日、25日，他们通过塞尔维亚大使给塞尔维亚发了信息。他们说，你们不能接受这份最后通牒。
That would be to commit suicide. You know, we will stand by you. They've almost effectively given the Serbians a blank check of their own. You stand firm and we'll sort this out for you. So the Serbians have their decision to make. The French are off at sea. But as you say, Tom, the big thing for the Russians is, do we get moving? Because we have to get cracking. If this is going to go horribly wrong, we can't mess around. So dawn breaks on the 25th of July. And of course, it's not a minor point. The Russians are deciding before everybody else. I mean, they're literally up before everybody else because of the time difference.
那等于自杀。你知道，我们会支持你们。他们几乎实际上给了塞尔维亚一张他们自己的空白支票。你们立场坚定，我们会为你们解决这个问题。所以塞尔维亚人必须做出决定。法国人在海上。但正如你所说，汤姆，对俄国人来说，最重要的事情是，我们开始行动吗？因为我们必须开始行动。如果这要变得非常糟糕，我们不能乱来。所以7月25日的黎明破晓。当然，这不是一个小点。俄国人在其他人之前做决定。我的意思是，因为时差，他们确实比其他人起得早。
So on Saturday, the 25th of July, they know that that evening, the decision will be made because the Serbians will have probably rejected the ultimatum. And so they meet in a place called Krasnoi Oselo, which is outside the capital. It's like one of the Tsar's summer palaces. He is there, Nicholas II. He's in a very fancy kind of white uniform of the guards, the Tsars. It's a beautiful day. It is that classic kind of a Viennese waltz.
所以7月25日星期六，他们知道那天晚上决定就会做出，因为塞尔维亚人可能已经拒绝了最后通牒。所以他们在首都外一个叫克拉斯诺耶塞洛的地方会面。这就像沙皇的夏宫之一。他在那里，尼古拉二世。他穿着非常华丽的沙皇卫队白色制服。这是一个美丽的日子。这是那种经典的维也纳华尔兹。
Piano in the back. The French windows are open to the garden, and they're a very incongruous scene. And he's sitting around with his ministers. And Sazonov says, guys, we need to start mobilizing our troops now. That will make an impression on Austria-Hungary. And what we'll do is we will mobilize just a bit of them. So the four Western military districts,
背景里有钢琴。法式落地窗对着花园，这是一个非常不协调的场景。他和他的部长们坐在一起。萨佐诺夫说，伙计们，我们需要现在开始动员我们的军队。那会对奥匈帝国产生影响。我们要做的就是动员他们的一小部分。所以四个西部军区，
that is Moscow, Kiev, Kazan, Odessa. So we will mobilize those. We'll cancel leave, reserve us back to the training camps, put the railways on alert, all of this kind of stuff. It's not full general mobilization, and it's not a declaration of war or anything like it, but it's just getting stuff going. Just a defensive measure. It's a defensive measure, but also that will show the Austrians that we are serious, and that will mean that the Austrians say, okay, enough, we've gone too far, we will back down.
即莫斯科、基辅、喀山、敖德萨。所以我们将动员那些。我们将取消休假，预备役回训练营，让铁路处于戒备状态，所有这些东西。这不是全面的总动员，也不是宣战或类似的事情，但这只是让事情运转起来。只是一个防御措施。这是一个防御措施，但也会向奥地利人表明我们是认真的，这意味着奥地利人会说，好吧，够了，我们走得太远了，我们会退缩。
Of course, this is an absolutely crucial point in the story, because at this moment, somebody is going to have to call off their mobilization and send everybody back home again, or the Austrians will have to not go through with the ultimatum that they have long prepared. So the stakes are suddenly very, very high now. And a Russian mobilization also has knock-on effects for Germany. It does indeed, because what are the Germans going to do? And all the time, the clock is ticking because at six o'clock this afternoon, Saturday, the 25th of July, the Serbs will have to give their answer to the Austrian ultimatum. episode, we will follow the course of those seven days that leads to apocalypse. And patriotic listeners will be delighted to know that in our next episode, Britain will enter the story. So if you're not a member of the Restless History Club, you'll be getting that in due course. If you are, you can get that straight away. And if you're not a member of the Rest Is History club, you'll be getting that in due course. If you are, you can get that straight away. And if you would like to join the club
当然，这是故事中绝对关键的一点，因为在这一刻，有人将不得不取消他们的动员并把所有人送回家，或者奥地利人将不得不不执行他们长期准备的最后通牒。所以现在的赌注突然变得非常、非常高了。俄国的动员对德国也有连锁反应。确实如此，因为德国人要做什么？而且一直以来，时钟都在滴答作响，因为今天下午六点，7月25日星期六，塞尔维亚人将不得不对奥地利的最后通牒给出答复。本集，我们将跟随那七天的进程，通往末日。爱国的听众会很高兴地知道，在我们的下一集中，英国将进入故事。所以如果你不是《余下皆历史》俱乐部的会员，你到时候会收到。如果你是，你可以马上得到。如果你不是《余下皆历史》俱乐部的会员，你到时候会收到。如果你是，你可以马上得到。如果你想加入俱乐部
and get immediate access, you can go to therestishistory.com. But until then, à bientôt. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
并立即获得访问权限，你可以前往therestishistory.com。但在此之前，à bientôt（再见）。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《余下皆娱乐》，这是你们每周的
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。